they were holding out on us amd's
launching yet another gpu and now the
gpu shortages
may be coming to an end heck maybe
you'll even be able to get one of these
at msrp
but why is this called the 6950xt
that's
weird isn't it and that's not the only
thing that's weird about this let's get
into it but first let's get into our
sponsor kiwiko kiwiko ships out crates
that contain hands-on projects for kids
to help develop their creative
confidence and problem solving skills
learn more at the end of the video or
right now at the link below
[Music]
want to know why this gpu is weird well
it's because it is the exact same gpu
as this one the 6900 xt almost literally
nothing has changed it's the same
silicon so i'm out of memory same
infinity cache same almost everything
the only differences are that the memory
is rated for 18 gigabits per second
instead of 16 and higher core clocks how
high less than 5 more across the board
but the board has more than 11 percent
higher power what is amd thinking how
could these tiny tweaks possibly
represent enough of a difference justify
a whole new skew well they didn't give
us a whole lot of time to figure it out
and they didn't even seat us a founder's
edition card instead letting msi handle
it giving us their gaming x trio sku to
compare against we have all of the
strongest cards but the one to watch out
for is the geforce rtx 3080 ti since on
paper it is the price competitor things
start off well for amd with f1 2021's
traditional rasterization performance
clearly favoring teamrez infinity cache
implementation that puts both the 6900
xt and the new 6500 xt well ahead of the
rtx 390 ti as much of a strength as
infinity cache is ray tracing is still
nvidia's home turf and amd loses by as
much as it gains when we switched it on
this pattern holds for far cry 6.2
although the performance gap with ray
tracing disabled isn't as wide as it was
for f1 neither is nvidia's lead with ray
tracing enabled with the 6950xt
basically neck and neck with the 30 90
ti
forza horizon 4 and hitman 3 both repeat
f1 2021's results almost perfectly with
a significant lead for team red's
refreshed gpu but microsoft flight
simulator appears to heavily favor
nvidia with a massive 24 lead in the
minimum frame rates cs go puts a cap on
it with another performance canyon i bet
with frame rates so high you're unlikely
to notice anyway
productivity though once amd's domain in
the years before rtx cards is now firmly
in nvidia's hands with significant
performance gaps and blender and we're
not even using the rtx accelerated
optics render here the performance of
the 6950xt is not unusable by any means
but you can get this level of
performance with a significantly cheaper
card from team green
puget bench is interesting because while
the test results are more or less the
same across creative cloud that premiere
score on the 6950 xt is a standout more
than just outpacing the 6900 xt it
pushes past even the rtx 3090ti to take
the crown here by about as much as that
card beats the 3080 ti
luxmark swings the pendulum back to
nvidia however as does indigo benchmark
amd's rdna 2 simply isn't as good at
these tasks as nvidia's ampere
architecture is at least with these
implementations and we can see more of
that with spec view perf where 3ds max
catia and creo all see radeons falling
behind the bump in memory bandwidth does
allow the 60 on 50 xt to pull ahead of
the pack in energy and medical tests
although solidworks is a bloodbath
although it's worth noting that spec
viewperf is using solidworks 2022 while
expanded gpu support landed in 2021.
thankfully spec has an application
benchmark for solidworks 2021 and we
have a license so after forcing the real
view accelerator to run on each gpu well
it's a lot closer but still about 25
percent slower than team green as with
any gpu that's factory overclocked the
thermal data should be taken with a
grain of salt with that said our msi
gaming x trio capped out at around the
same high 70s core temperature as the
amd built 6900 xt which is slightly
higher than either g-force card but
still pretty manageable
why not hire well the hotspot
temperatures tell a different story with
the 6950xt hovering around the mid-90s
at the hottest sensor and 3090 just
going to the moon a sensor is probably
memory as we've seen those in the past
but still just
wow the 3090 ti doesn't even get the
high although it is the ega ftw3 with a
big beefy cooler kind of like our
swaggetts from lttstore.com beefy but
not too beefy good most of the year up
here in the great white north now we do
need to have a discussion about power
consumption in our testing the 6950xt
powered around
450 watts with a peak of over 500 which
is just ridiculous
only the rtx 3090 ti goes higher and not
by all that much
amd tells us this isn't normal behavior
so it's definitely not msi here with
their factory overclock but it's yet
another indicator of the terrifying
future where gpus and especially
third-party cards will draw ever more
power in a bid to one-up each other even
if it means that we need a dedicated
circuit just for our pc all for a
factory overclock god for what it's
worth that factory overclock was
relatively stable although it did
decline from 2.5 gigahertz to around
2.42
it's worth mentioning that stock cards
will often overshoot the boost clocks if
they're able to anyway so it's tough to
say what a reference 6950xt
might look based on this data alone
at the end of the day you're paying 10
more for 10 more performance which in
the same generation is fine by me
especially considering the premium in
video placed on the rtx 39ati but there
are some questions that remain
unanswered here this card is the exact
same silicon as the 6900xt
which means amd binned them so they
could sell them at a higher price point
rather than contribute to the 6900 xt
supply that amd told us these gpus will
be adding to supply supports that theory
but when you look at the retail pricing
for the 6900xt as of writing the
conclusion of corporate greed you might
come to becomes less clear
yeah some cards are available at around
the original launch price but a lot of
them are as expensive or more than the
6950xt that launches today so you're
spending less money overall for a better
gpu out of the box
assuming you can get one of these for
its 1100 launch price
all of which is to say i don't hate this
true it's not a game changer and it's
far from a good value for productivity
but it doesn't have to be either of
those things
from our testing it at minimum trades
blows in gaming with a gpu that costs
nearly double depending on the game
at a time when availability and pricing
for radeon gpus is coming back down to
earth this puts amb in a position where
paradoxically their over a thousand
dollar gpu is a good deal by comparison
i can't believe i just said that
but i can believe that i'm going to tell
you a better sponsor kiwi co kiwico is a
monthly subscription service to help
introduce and make stem topics fun and
engaging for kids of all ages they
believe if you start learning small
things today you can produce
world-changing ideas tomorrow each crate
is designed by experts and contains
everything you need to complete it with
detailed kid-friendly instructions
maybe even i can understand it this
means you don't need to run off to the
store to get extra supplies like glue or
scissors cubico offers nine subscription
lines each catering to different age
groups and topics the crate we have here
is at a kiwi level for kids age three
and up that teaches accounting sorting
and fine motor skills another one is the
tinker level for your tweens and teams
aged 9-16 which explores air vortices
and fluid dynamics with an air cannon
kiwico is a great way to keep kids
occupied for hours so they just leave
you alone and they now ship to over 40
different countries with kiwico you're
not just teaching your kids to buy
you're teaching them to build so go to
kiwico.com
ltt30 and get 30 off your first month on
any crate so thanks for watching hit
like get subscribed and maybe after this
you want to see
well we didn't put an amd gpu in it but
the hot wheels pc we put an rtx 39 yet
and it was freaking sweet